اعلن الاسطول الخامس الامريكي نشره ثلاثه
الاف جندي وعدد من القطع البحريه في الشرق
الاوسط كجزء من خطه امريكيه لتخفيف
التوترات الناجمه عن مضايقات ايران
ومصادرتها السفن في الخليج بحسب قوله من
جانبها انتقدت طهران هذه الخطوه واكدت ان
دول المنطقه اقدر على حمايه امنها وتوعدت
بالرد على ما سمتها اي استفزازات
الامريكيه محتمله في الخليج
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الاهداف التي تسعى
واشنطن لتحقيقها بارسال كل هذه التعزيزات
العسكريه الى الشرق الاوسط وفي هذا
التوقيت وما واجهه اسباب التوجس الايراني
من هذه الاجراءات على اي نحو يمكن ان
ينعكس تعزيز واشنطن وجودها العسكري في
المنطقه على منظومه امنها في ضوء حرص
طهران على مقابله ذلك بتطوير قدراتها
الحربيه في الخليج وما المالات المحتمله
لامن الخليج في ضوء ارتفاع التوتر بين
طهران و واشنطن على خلفيه هذه التحركات
وكيف سينعكس ذلك على الخلافات المرتبطه
بملف ايران النووي
[موسيقى]
في اطار خطه لتعزيز الوجود العسكري
الامريكي في المنطقه تقول واشنطن انها
تهدف لردع ما تسميه نشاط ايران المزعزع
للاستقرار واحتجازها السفن وناقله النفط
فان اكثر من ثلاثه الاف من جنود البحريه
وصلوا الاحد الى الشرق الاوسط حسب ما افاد
الاسطول الخامس الامريكي تعزيزات واشنطن
العسكريه في المنطقه التي تؤكد انها دليل
على التزامها القوي والثابت بالامن البحري
الاقليمي وعلى حرصها على العمل جنبا الى
جنب مع الحلفاء لحمايته تشمل ايضا قطعا
حربيه امريكيه من بينها السفينه الهجوميه
البرمائيه يو اس اس باتان وسفينه الانزال
uss كارتر هول اللتان اكد الاسطول الخامس
انهما دخلت البحر الاحمر عبر بعد عبورهما
قناه السويس
ردوا طهران على الانتشار العسكري الامريكي
في المنطقه جاء من اكثر من جهه الحرس
الثوريه الذي هدد بالرد بالمثل على اي
توقيف واحتجاز امريكي محتمله لسفن ايرانيه
اكد امتلاكه القدره والقرار لمواجهه مسماه
اي تصعيد امريكي اما الخارجيه الايرانيه
التي اكدت ان امن المنطقه يتحقق عبر تعاون
دولها فقد رفضت ايه تدخل خارجي في امور
تتعلق بامن المنطقه واضافت الخارجيه
الايرانيه ان الانتشار العسكري الامريكي
في الشرق الاوسط هدفه خدمه مصالح واشنطن
وحدها وانه لم يقض ابدا الى جلب الامن
للمنطقه
[موسيقى]
الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
مدير التعاون الدولي السابق في البيت
الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس الاسبق بارك
اوباما من طهران حسين رويوران الباحث
المتخصص في القضايا الاقليميه
والاستراتيجيه ومن عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي مرحبا
بكم جميعا سيد بروين ما دواعي هذا التوجه
الامريكي
من الواضح ان الخطر قد ازداد
طبعا واشنطن تشعر بقلق نتيجه بعض الخطوات
التي
اتخذتها طهران خلال الاشهر الماضيه
ومنها
تردد ايران في الدخول اي مفاوضات جاده
وتتذكرون وجمهوركم يتذكر بان ايران لديها
تاريخ طويل فيما يمكن نسميهما بالنشاطات
خارج
المقرر فقط هاجمت الولايات المتحده مصالح
الولايات المتحده وغيرها في المنطقه وهذا
طبعا هذا الخطر اصبح وهذا اصبح كبيرا
وبالتالي فواصل تخرج الخطوات اللازمه
للتاكد من اندفاعاتنا سواء كانت السفن او
مؤسسه اخرى ايضا لارسال رساله الى طهران
بان اجراء اي هجمات على السفن او على
المؤسسات
سيواجه
برد سريع وقوي اذا سيد حسين كما يقول
السيد برين بانها رساله لطهران كيف وصلت
لايران كيف تنظرون الى هذا التواجد
العسكري المتواتر للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في مضيق هرمز تحديدا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحياتي لك ولضيوف
الكرام والمشاهدين الاعزاء يعني في تصوري
ان التصعيد هو امريكي وليس ايراني لان
ايران عندما احتجزت الناقلات احتجزت ذلك
في اطار رد الفعل على احتجاز ناقله
ايرانيه في جنوب شرق اسيا
وسرقه نفطها من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لماذا تقوم امريكا
بتوير الاجواء في تصوري المتلقي لهذا
الموضوع هو طرفان احدهما ايران والطرف
الاخر هو دول المنطقه
اذا كانت امريكا تتصور انها تستطيع من
خلال يعني هذا التحشيد للقوات ان تفرض
شيئا على ايران فاتصور ان التاريخ
يعني يثبت ان ايران لن تنصاع للضغوط ولم
في السابق يعني انصاعت لهذه الضغوط من هنا
امريكا هي تخطئ مره اخرى في استعمال اليه
ثبت فشلها اما اذا كان المتلقي غير ايران
توتير الاجواء يدفع دول المنطقه
للعوده تحت المظله الامنيه الامريكيه
ويمنع التفلت الذي حصل خلال السنوات
الماضيه باتجاه روسيا والصين من قبل بعض
الدول في المنطقه من هنا اتصور ان المتلقي
الاساسي
لهذا التوثير هو ايران ايران هي من باب
المبرر تطرحه امريكا ولكن امريكا تريد ان
تخاطب الدول في المنطقه في البقاء تحت
المظله الامريكيه وعدم الخروج عن قراراتها
طيب اللواء الدويري قبل ان نتحدث عن
المؤشرات اريد ان اتحدث عن طبيعه هذه
السفن منها سفينه انزال حربيه كيف تفهم
طبيعه هذا الانتشار العسكري البحري
الامريكي في المنطقه
يعني هو تعزيز لما هو موجود هو ليس حشد
قوه بمعنى حشد القوه يوجد في المنطقه
الاستور الخامس
قيادته في البحرين في المنام
يوجد به حامل الطائرات يوجد به 17 قطعه
بحريه قتاليه ما بين غواصه ما بين فرقاطه
ما بين مدمره ما بين
سفينه انزال او ابرار الان تم تعزيز القوه
بقطعتين بحريتين
وتم تعزيز القوه البشريه بثلاث الاف جندي
من المشاه البحريه هو اصلا يوجد 3500 يوجد
اكثر من 70 طائره يوجد عشرات الطائرات
العموديه فبالتالي بلقي القوه الرئيسي هو
اصلا موجود ولكن هذا تعزيز الا ماذا هذا
تعزيز
لماذا هذا التعزيز هو لماذا يؤشر تم اجراء
مناوره قبل تقريبا عده ايام
محور المناوره يدور حول الدفاع عن الجزر
في مياه الخليج العربي منها الجزر
المتنازع عليها اللي هي ابو موسى
يضاف الى ذلك تم
الافصاح عن سفن جديده مزوده بصواريخ سواء
صواريخ كروز او صواريخ
من انواع اخرى باليستيه يصل مداها الى 600
كيلو متر وبالتالي هناك تنامي في القوه
يعني من وجهه النظر الامريكيه تنامي في
التهديد كان هناك خبر صدر عن الجانب
الامريكي بعد عمليات احتجاز السفن بان
امريكا طيب ستلجا الى استخدام جنود مشابه
على السفن التجاريه بعد الاتفاق
الاتفاقات الثنائيه مع الدول التي ترفع
على ترفع اعلام اعلامها على هذه السفن اذا
كما اقول لك هو تعزيز لما هو موجود واضح
تعزيز قد يرقى الى المستوى النوعي ولكن
ليس بالتع كبير جدا الذي يؤشر الى ما وراء
الاكمه طيب
السيد حسين رويوران قبل قليل قال بان هذه
الاليه اثبتت فشلها
يعني هذا يعيد شبح العسكره الى الى
المنطقه الا يزيد هذا من فرص الاحتكاك
المباشر ونذكر بان الحرس الثوري الايراني
اسقط في عام 20 20 الطائره المسيره جلوبال
هوك الامريكيه فوق سماء المنطقه الا يفتح
هذا مجالا للمواجهه المباشره
لو اننا تركنا طهران
تواصل ودون مواجهه تواصلت تهديداتها
ونشاطاتها العسكريه فان ذاك فعلا المنطقه
ستعرض المزيد الاخلال بالاستقرارها وعليه
هناك قوه ردع ولا بد ان هناك قدره على
الرد وقد شاهدنا فعلا في حاله روسيا ما
حصل عندما لم تكن هناك
ردا قويا وسريعا على التهديدات واعتقد ان
اشرطه تعلمت درسا من ذلك وكما يمكن القول
اقول صديقي في ايران انه ليست الولايات
المتحده هي التي تختطف السفن وليست
الولايات المتحده التي
ترسل المصاريخ تسقط على على مواقع مختلفه
مختلف الدول المنطقه اذا ايران هي
المحفز والمؤدي الى كل هذا
لديها فرصه عند اداره بايدن
للمتفاوض بحسن نوايا ولكن لم يستجيبوا
بصراحه المسؤوليه تقع على عاتقهم لان بعد
دارت ترامب جاءت اداره بايدن وهي تطلع الى
استعاده الحياه لفاق النووي مع ايران ولكن
طهران كانت بصراحه غبيه بصراحه بطريقه
تعاملها مع تلك المفاوضات والان نجد
انفسنا في موقف
نحن نعود فيه الى النشاط العسكري
والولايات المتحده تتخذ هذه الردود هذا
العمل ردا على الهجمات على السفن وعلى
منشات اخرى او هذا يتطلب منا من امريكا ان
تبعث برساله واضحه الى طهران بان هذا
النوع من السلوك لن يسمح به ولن نقبل
وسيكون من الحكمه لايران ان تصغي الينا
تتراجع عن هذا النوع من الاستفزازات وان
تعود الى مائده المفاوضات بحسن نيه لفت
بانك تربط ما بين التعزيزات العسكريه في
المنطقه ومن بين المفاوضات حول ملف ايران
نووي ساعود الى هذا الملف في المحور
الاخير سيد حسين اللواء الدويري اشار الى
المناورات التي حصلت قبل ايام وبالمناسبه
هي انطلقت من جزيره ابو موسى المتنازع
عليها كيف تنوي ايران مواجهه هذه
التعزيزات العسكريه البحريه
يعلم في حق طبيعي مكتسب لكل الدول
لرفع الكفاءه القتاليه ولا اتصور ان
الموضوع
هو يعني يستفز الاخر نعم ايران الان تمتلك
صواريخ كروز بمدى الف كيلو متر يعني دعني
اصحح ليس 600 بل الف كيلو متر
الان صواريخ سليمان وابو مهدي دخلت من
خلال هذه المناوره
يعني الى الخدمه لماذا عندما كانت ايران
لا تمتلك هذه الامكانيات يعني الضيف
الكريم من امريكا يقول انه امريكا لا تخ
لا تختطف السفن امريكا احد اكبر الدول في
ارتكاب الجرائم امريكا هي التي ضربت
القنبله النوويه امريكا ضربت طائره مدنيه
ايرانيه عام
1988 87
خلينا نبقى في في الموضوع تحديدا مع انها
طائره مدنيه لا لا ما اريد نقول امريكا
اغرقت عشرات السفن الايرانيه في
سنوات حرب الخليج الاولى الان نعم ايران
تمتلك قوه رادعه وتحاول ان تستعملها
وتحاول ان تستعرضها لمنع الحرب لماذا
امريكا في المنطقه لانها قوه امبرياليه
هذه المنطقه هي تخص الدول المتشاطئه وليست
امريكا لماذا تاتي الى هنا لماذا تريد ان
تفرض شيئا على هذا او ذاك طب يعني
مباشره في حال حدث اي تصادم ايرانيه ابدا
طيب
ايران ايران لن تبدا اي حرب مع اي طرف في
المنطقه حتى امريكا
طيب باستثناء الكيانه الصهيوني طيب يعني
من ايران ستدافع عن نفسها واضح اذا تعرضت
لاي هجوم
الطرفان حرص على مدى اربعه عقود على عدم
المواجهه المباشره هل سيبقى الامر كذلك
ذكر لك السيد حسين عن صواريخ كروز سليماني
وابو مهدي الف كيلو متر في ظل هذه
التعزيزات والتوتر الحاصل ما امكانيه
واحتماليه المواجهه
يعني بس اشاره لتعليق ضيفك الكريم انا
تحدثت حسب وسائل الاعلام الايرانيه حول
صاروخ فتح وقدير ولم اتحدث عن بقيه
الصواريخ لديها صواريخ تصل 2000 كيلو متر
هذا الامر واضح جدا الان
اربع عقود من الصراع والترقب وعدم حدوث
مواجهه مفتوحه لماذا لان عواقب المواجهه
المفتوحه على جنى كلا الجانبين ثقيل جدا
وان كانت على الجانب الايراني اكثر قسوه
الان هي رسائل ردع ورسائل تحذير قد يحدث
عمليات استفزاز قد يحدث عمليات احتكاك
يمكن احتوائها لكن لن تحدث مواجهه مفتوحه
لجمله اسباب اهم هذه الاسباب فارق القوه
في المستوى والسياق الاستراتيجي ما بين
البحريه الايراني والبحريه الامريكيه
القابله للتعزيز
واصبحت ايران اكثر قدره على المواجهه
والردع
نعم احترم رايه وساجيب الان هناك البحريه
الايرانيه وبحريه الحرس الثوري الايراني
البحريه الايرانيه عشرين الف والحرس
الثوره الايراني 18000 البحريه الايرانيه
يوجد بها فرقاطات وغواصات ومدمرات وحارقات
البحريه الحرس الثوري يوجد معظمها زوارق
حربيه سريعه قابله للتفجير وعمليات
الاقتحام ويوجد فيها المدفعيه الساحليه
انا اعرف ما هي القدرات واتحدث بناء على
معلومات موثقه الان اذا قارنا هذه القدره
انا لا اقول انها غير مؤثره لا اقول انها
غير فاعله هذه الفاعله في عمليات الازعاج
عمليات الاشتباكات المحدوده الاشتباكات
المفاجئه ما يسمى ما يطلق عليها خاصه
بحريه الحرس الثوري الايراني طيب توضع تحت
عنوان يدرس عمليات
عمليات العصابات البحريه لكن عندما اضعها
امام حامل الطائرات قابله للتزويد
بحاملتين وبالتالي هنا
برق القوه الرئيسي لا يسمح لايران بمواجهه
مفتوحه شامله لكن نعم تستطيع الحاق الضرر
تستطيع الازعاج تستطيع التشويش تستطيع
الارباك لكن لا تستطيع المواجهه اذا هي
لعبه
اصابع من اجل اثبات القدره والذات اكثر
منه من اجل المواجهه مسؤولون امريكيون
صرحوا لعدد من وسائل الاعلام بان
الفانتاكن يدرس نشر او تواجد جنود من
البارينز على حاملات للنفط عند مرورها
بمضيق هرمز
لردع ايران من اي مضايقات لهذه الحملات هل
هذا قانوني تواجد عسكري على حاملات نفط
مدنيه وايضا مره جديده الا يزيد هذا من
احتماليه المواجهه المباشره في حال اقدمت
ايران فعليا او زورق ايراني على اعتراض
هذه الحامله الا يفتح هذا مجالا اوسع
للمواجهه المباشره
جواب هو فعل هذا العمل هو قانوني وطبعا لو
ان هذه الناقلات المدنيه تعرض خطر هجوم
كما حصل في ما حصل مع من
فاذا هناك ضروره لخلق مثل هذه
الفقاعه الحمائيه حول
الناقلات التي تستطيع ان تمر بامان في
مياه البحر الدوليه مع الاسف نحن وصلنا
الى هذه النقطه لنجد سيدنا ايران تواصل
التصعيد وتواصل
رفعه مستوى المخاطر والولايات المتحده
تقول انه ليس فقط لاجل انما الاقتصاد
العالمي في صراحه
لكي يستطيع الجميع الشاحنات وعفوا
الناقلات تعتمر نحتاج ان يكون
لهذه نوع من الامان لحمايه وبالتالي بعد
ان هذه القوى الزوارق الايرانيه صغيره
تحاول ازعاجها واحيانا الواقع حتى الصعود
الى
ظهر هذه الناقلات سيترددون في ذلك ويفكرون
عمليا في ذلك
ويفكر هل يريدون فقط ان يدخلوا في معركه
تبادل اطلاق نار مع البحروشات البحريه
الامريكيه
تحول الى المحور الاخير سيد حسين
قبل ايام بحث قائد القوات البحريه
الامريكيه في القياده المركزيه والاسطول
الخامس مع امين عام مجلس التعاون الدول
الخليج العربي تع زيز الامن اهميه
الاستراتيجيات تعزيز الامن
البحري بالمنطقه كيف ترون توقيت هذه
الزياره وهذا البحث وما نتج بعده من تعزيز
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لقواتها في
المنطقه
يعني اعود واؤكد ان امريكا تريد انهاء
حاله التفلت لبعض دول المنطقه
واعادتها الى الحظيره الامريكيه يعني
بعباره ادق كان هناك اتفاق بين بحريه
دول المنطقه في ايجاد مركز للتنسيق
وايران والسعوديه والامارات وعمان يعني كل
هذه الدول وقعت على هذا التفاهم في ان
يكون هناك
تنسيق فيما بينها في كل الامور التي تخص
منطقه الخليج الفارسي ولكن امريكا الان
تشعر ان هناك
من يحاول ان يقلل من يعني الحضور الامريكي
والهيمنه الامريكيه اساسا في المنطقه
ولهذا امريكا تحاول ان تعيد هذه الدول الى
ما كانت عليه من تبعيه امنيه
لامريكا هل دول منطقه تستطيع حفظ الامن
فيها نعم هذا لطالما تكرر على لسان اكثر
المسؤول في اكثر من دوله في المنطقه لماذا
الحضور الامريكي لان امريكا تريد ان تفرض
نفسها والا دول المنطقه تمتلك شكرا من
الامكانات العسكريه والامكانات المختلفه
لحفظ الامن في المنطقه السيد طبعا انت كما
اسلفت ربطت اكثر من مره ما بين هذا
التعزيز العسكري والملف النووي الايراني
هل هو ترجمه هذا التعزيز العسكري هل هو
ترجمه لسياسه العصا والجزره التي تستخدمها
الولايات المتحده لح ث ايران على تنازلات
اكبر ربما في الملف النووي والتفاوضات
المفاوضات التي تحصل بوسطات
اعتقد ان ايران قد فوتت على نفسها فرصه
كبيره عندما وصلت اداره للسلطه
بالعوده الى بسرعه الى الاتفاق النووي
بالاثاره القضايا كثيره لا علاقه لها
وتحديات كبيره اوقفت المفاوضات اذا ما
نشهدها الان هو ان ايران تحاول زياده
الضغوط على واشنطن وعلى دول المنطقه وذلك
لاجبارها على قبول بعض هذه الامور
وفي نهايه مطاف لكي تحصل على نوع من
التخفيف العقوبات عليها اعتقد ان هذا
اسلوب او طريقه غبيه لانه كما ذكرتم انتم
ان ذلك يدعو الى زياده النزاع والحرب والى
المزيد من خلال الاستقرار وهذا سيرفع
الاسعار ويزيدها وايضا يزيدها احتمالات
خساره حياه بشر غير ضروريه علينا ان نفهم
ان القوات العسكريه الامريكيه لا غير
منتشره
بشكل هجومي ولا يستطيعون ولا يدوس كيف
يمكن الصعوده الى
ظهر السفن الايرانيه بل فقط طريقه حمايه
حلفائنا وهذه السفن والناقلات وشكرا ان
توقف هجماتها وتهديداتها ولذا اعتقد
نستطيع ان نتحدث شكرا لكم جميعا
شكرا في واشنطن السيد بريت بروين في طهران
السيد حسين رويوران وفي عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعه الى
اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]